we're going to begin this morning though
with travel warnings for dangerous
weather gripping much of the nation this
weekend millions are bracing for impact
as storms punch their way from the
Rockies to the Northeast a separate
system is expected to bring snow and
heavy rain to the west the National
Weather Service warns Travel could
become impossible in some places in
Arizona the search continues for three
young children who disappeared when the
Motorhome in which their family was
traveling with swept away by floodwaters
90 miles northeast of Phoenix in
Colorado powerful winds forced some
drivers to pull to the side of the major
highway there a tractor trailer tipped
over in Colorado Springs Wow look at
that
no word on injuries whiteout driving
conditions were treacherous north of
Minneapolis and similar scenes are
likely to play out from millions of
others as the storm moves east
meteorologist Jeff beard Ellie is here
with the forecast Jeff good morning
trouble for a lot of people out there
yeah that is for sure good morning Dana
good morning to you at home I mean even
for a meteorologist this has been a
remarkable storm with many different
faces right now that face is a blizzard
in the Upper Midwest and plane States as
you can see lots of severe weather along
this front as well so it's producing a
lot of different types of weather
showers thunderstorms and on the north
side winds gusting to 40 50 miles an
hour blizzard conditions in Rapid City
look at how colorful that map is 70
million people impacted by winter
weather and wind alerts right now as we
speak so there's that blizzard Rapid
City sure on Bismarck all the way to
Fargo there's the threat for severe
weather later today into the evening in
the deep south watch what happens the
storm is gonna get strung out if you
will move from Minneapolis becoming an
ice storm tomorrow in the Northeast then
transitioning to a nor'easter where it's
going to snow heavily just north of New
York just west of Boston even the major
cities could see accumulating snow as
well this is how much snow that we
expect Alber Midwest a lot of folks
gonna get 6 to 12 plus inches of snow in
some areas and look at that bull's eye
in the Northeast if you're a skier grab
him
head up to the Catskills head up to the
Berkshires head up to the green and
white mountains of Vermont New Hampshire
18 inches of snow is possible
yikes a lot of us are in trouble thank
you Jeff